to take a couple of questions
about our vaccine strategy in view of
recent
developments so i give the floor to the
commissioner for an initial statement
thank you good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen
i last communicated with your monday
to express our serious concerns
regarding the intention of astrazeneca
to supply considerable considerably
fewer doses
in the coming weeks then agreed and
announced
since then we have been making all
efforts to resolve the situation
we convened a third meeting of the
steering board on monday
night which resulted again in
insufficient explanations from the
company
and deep dissatisfaction among the
member states
now let me be crystal clear the 27
european union member states are united
that astrazeneca needs to deliver on its
commitments
in our agreements we are in a pandemic
we lose people every day these are not
numbers
they're not statistics these are persons
with families with friends and
colleagues
that are all affected as well
pharmaceutical companies
vaccine developers have moral societal
and contractual responsibilities which
they need
to uphold the view that the company is
not obliged to deliver
because we signed a best effort
agreement
is neither correct nor is it acceptable
we signed an advance purchase agreement
for a product which at the time
did not exist and which still today is
not
yet authorized and we signed it
precisely
to ensure that the company builds a
manufacturing capacity
to produce the vaccine early so that
they can deliver a certain volume of
doses
the day that it is authorized the logic
of these agreements was as valid then as
it is now
we provide a de-risking investment up
front
in order to get a binding commitment
from the company to pre-produce
even before it gets authorization
not being able to ensure manufacturing
capacity is against the letter
and the spirit of our agreement we
reject
the logic of first come first served
that may work at the neighborhood
butchers but not in contracts and not in
our advanced purchase agreements
there's no priority clause in the
advanced purchase agreement
and also no there is also no hierarchy
of the four production plans
named in the advanced purchase agreement
two are in the united
in the eu and two are located in the uk
now we intend to defend the integrity of
our investments
and the taxpayers money that has been
invested
we remain always open to engage with the
company to resolve
any outstanding issues in the spirit of
true collaboration
and responsibility that was always the
spirit of our engagement with vaccine
manufacturers
since last spring this evening
at 6 30 the steering board
will convene again i call on astrazeneca
to engage fully to rebuild trust
to provide complete information and to
live up to its contractual
societal and moral obligations
thank you very much thank you very much
commissioner we will now take
a few questions and
i start with patricia antonini from anza
thank you commissioner thank you eric um
so i would like to understand a little
bit more this
best uh possible effort um
because the i mean we saw the interview
and the ceo is pretty much
pushing on that point and
is it possible also to know uh
what were the numbers of the deliveries
due to
the eu in the first quarter and
thank you
commissioner yes thank you for that uh
the well i i think that some of these
questions were already answered by
by my director general in the technical
briefing
i just want to touch on on one or two
points
the the best effort clause is there
because the vaccine hadn't been
developed or authorized and that's why
it's called an advanced purchase
agreement
but we did select the company on the
basis of its production capacity
uh so they're supposed to to be able to
produce in time
the logic was that the company makes a
build a binding commitment to
pre-produce to the best of its ability
taking a risk even it before it gets
authorization and we accept that risk
that if the authorization is not given
we have invested
at a loss but we did not invest
in the company in the assumption that
they will not be able to pre
uh produce so investing and ramping up
pre-production
capacity was one of the premises of our
agreement
um i think the other question was on the
numbers um
in terms of uh of the numbers paid to
astrazeneca
i think that information is confidential
and can only be shared with the
conference with the agreement of the
company thank you as you know we have
asked the company to be able to publish
uh the contract and hope therefore to be
able uh to provide the information
um publicly i now move to
verena schmidt
verena
yes it's happening thank you very much
for the question
um the ceo said that
the eu was uh um i think
two months after the british uh to sign
the contract
was the eu just simply too late and
is the the vaccine that was that could
have been used in the eu
being used in in the uk and elsewhere
instead
so that we are losing out thank you
thank you for that question um i really
don't want to go into
uh take this uh using this opportunity
that i have to share
uh our position with you uh commenting
on what the ceo has
has said what i will say is what i said
in my opening statement
in our contract it is not specified
that any country or the uk has priority
because it's signed
earlier i contract foresees a quarter by
quarter
schedule and if this was the case
hashtag
should have proposed a clause in the
contract acknowledging that they will
prioritize for example deliveries to the
uk
um saying saying this but there is no
such clause in the contract
and uh let me add one thing that um uh
we are here because we need to put in
our best efforts in order
to solve this situation uh as many of
you
know they were difficulties that we had
with biontech
just under two weeks ago we worked
together we sold them so what we are
asking
uh here of of astrazeneca is that
uh we that they are as open and
transparent
with what the situation is so that we
can move forward
so that we can resolve the situation for
the benefit of all european
and not only european citizens thank you
thank you um i go to direct
perhaps it will be in french
hello
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
could we repeat the translation of the
of the question please
sorry because it took a bit of time to
get to derek perhaps ask your question
again because it was a bit of a
an issue with setting up the translation
channel
yeah i'll do it in english i'll do it in
english um
are you sure will we get this best
effort uh closer problem in the next
uh with the next vaccines are you sure
that uh johnson and johnson or kerr
or kovac won't have the same
difficulties
and won't claim that they have only a
best
effort clause not a number
not a commitment
thank you very much derek for the
question well if they follow and stick
to our advanced purchase agreements
there won't be any problems and
advanced purchase agreements guarantees
the manufacturing capacity
thank you thank you
i now move to david hassenhorn
david you have the floor
okay there we go thank you eric so much
for the uh for the question
uh commissioner if if i can ask you just
to clarify and follow up again on
patricia's point about the numbers
we understand from the previous
briefings that the eu had an expectation
now the contract may have said you know
best effort but the eu had an
expectation of a certain number of doses
that expectation was adjusted or changed
by estrogenica at the beginning of
december and then again on friday
so i wonder if you could run us through
those numbers um and then on
two other quick points the eu is
obviously
eu member states are not the only
countries relying on production
in the eu and so i wonder if you've been
in touch with other partners
say like canada for instance or south
africa countries that also have
contracts
that aren't relying on first in line at
the butcher shop as you said
and are worried now that the eu's own
oversights and controls will put europe
first
do you have assurances to them that this
will be worked out
in some reasonable fashion and then
maybe the last one is
are there thoughts that the commission
should be focused on other vaccines you
obviously invested in all candidates
that were viable that in fact production
may not increase from master zenica no
matter what
how many times you argue with them
before the steering board are there
other things you could be doing
say with bio intact pfizer or other
vaccines to get at the real issue which
is how do you get more vaccine faster
for european citizens thank you
um i'll just be i'll try and be as brief
as possible
first of all in terms of the numbers
what i can tell you and uh it was also
stressed before that the numbers that
were
shared with us on friday by the company
did not correspond to what
was in the advanced purchase agreement
and to our advice and to what we uh
we expected uh in terms of our global
partners of course we're in continuous
contact with our global partners
um uh and through the g7 through the g7
and and i work very closely of course
with who
and i wanted to make a point clear
because uh
uh we're talking uh about um uh uh
you you spoke about export restrictions
but uh let me
be absolutely clear the the european
union is not expected this is not
imposing an export ban
on vaccines or it or restricting
the export of vaccines to third
countries
what we have proposed as a commission is
an export transparency mechanism
which will be what it will do is bring
clarity
uh on the production capacity of
manufacturers the number of doses
as i already have said to you two days
ago produced
which production centers and which doses
are sold to which countries
including the eu 27 and this is very
important to have this
transparency and clarity uh of
of deliveries and this is what we're
working towards
um we are asking uh as
um ms lamere said before uh
we are requesting of astrazeneca to
be as transparent as possible with the
contracts we believe that sharing these
will clarify many of the issues and the
questions raised
thank you thank you we'll take two more
questions lotte
you have the floor
can you hear me yes go ahead
yeah thank you for giving me the
question and thank you
commissioner i just want to to know uh
there's been a lot of discussion about
eu
being too late about ordering the
medicine
were you told by essa seneca that
because you ordered
uh so late that they say you know
you finish your order in october were
you told by them
that then they might not be able to
fulfill the contract
that there might be problems giving you
the doses
at a certain time thank you
no i categorically reject this
they signed an agreement so my answer is
very simple no thank you
last question marcus price
my question to the commissioner is the
following um
[Music]
if because i i did not get a clear
answer so far
if the production in the uk is better
than in the european union
do you expect astrazeneca to shift
vaccine doses
from the uk to the eu is my first
question and the second
do you have any indication that
production of vaccine doses in the eu
was already shifted to the uk thank you
right i'll try and readdress that
question
[Music]
let me be clear there is no hierarchy of
the factories
uh you are aware that the in the
contracts there are four
i think four factories listed but it
does not differentiate between
um uh the uk and the europe the uk
factories are part of our advanced
purchase agreements
and this is why they have to deliver um
on on the doses being shifted we
we expect the doses that are in an
advanced purchase of grievance
agreements to be uh delivered to the
european union
um in in this sense it is important that
we
we clarify this because there was no
hierarchy
or order in terms of the fourth of the
factories that were in the advanced
purchase agreements and this needs to be
absolutely clear
um so um
i didn't understand if there was a final
question did i miss a question
um yes there was another question
sorry i'm sorry i missed the last
question i was
but uh yes i think the question i think
the last question was
what i will say here is that no company
should be under any illusion
that we don't have the means to uh
understand what is happening
and so we ask all companies to be as
transparent as possible
with the information because so that we
do
know um and this is what we have asked
of the company
so we do have a a knowledge of
the production of the doses where they
were produced and if they have been sent
anywhere where this is
thank you thank you very much
for your attention this brings us to the
end of the press conference
thank you commissioner thank you
you